el país más represivo del mundo para las
mujeres hacía catalogado Naciones Unidas
a Afganistán desde su regreso al poder
en agosto de 2021 el régimen talibana
multiplicado las medidas liberticias
contra las mujeres ahora las que quieren
Acceder al conocimiento ya no tienen
esta posibilidad la enseñanza secundaria
y la universidad les están prohibidas
con ocasión del 8 de marzo una veintena
de ellas pudieron manifestarse en kabul
y recordar al mundo sus privaciones
estamos aquí reunidas para expresar
nuestras reivindicaciones y todas
tenemos la misma exigencia que se
vuelvan a abrir las puertas de las
escuelas y que hagamos uso de nuestro
derecho inalienable a tener un país
autosuficiente
si quedarnos en casa nos lleva al cielo
Entonces no quiero ir allí mientras
creen tantas restricciones sobre qué
llevar y cómo llevarlo si un hombre que
te mira no debe sentirse tentado
Entonces por qué no se cubren los ojos
porque no se ponen una máscara en los
ojos o en la boca para no mirar a las
mujeres por qué Por qué tenemos que
estar siempre bajo la presión de los
hombres
además de la educación las mujeres
también han sido excluidas de muchos
empleos públicos tampoco se les permite
viajar sin un familiar varón Así mismo
en noviembre los talibanes les
prohibieron la entrada a parques
jardines gimnasios y baños públicos con
la mitad de la población afgana
enfrentada a una grave inseguridad
alimentaria la ONU Calcula que para 2023
11,6 millones de mujeres y niñas afganas
necesitarán ayuda humanitaria la
comunidad internacional acondicionado la
existencia a que los talibanes respeten
los derechos humanos en particular los
de las mujeres una condición Que hasta
el momento no parece ejercer presión
sobre